[Musique]
malgré son air austère paul gérin lajoie
fut l'un des plus modernes et des plus
idéaliste des ministres de jean lesage
quand l'avocat diplômés des universités
de montréal et d'oxford obtient le
ministère de la jeunesse en 1960
plus de la moitié des adultes du québec
non complété qu'une sixième année
imaginez tout le système d'éducation de
a à z relevé de l'église
ils créent sur le champ la commission
parent le but d'établir un véritable
ministère de l'éducation et de rapatrier
le plus rapidement possible toutes les
responsabilités en matière
d'enseignement
tout le monde sait qu'un politique la
vie est éphémère
alors si on veut pas les choses à deux
trois ou quatre ans qu'on a la chance
des cas ça ne se fait pas sa fougue et 6
visée choqueront dans plusieurs milieux
influents du québec que en principe
l'état doit se mêler de l'enseignement
on craint qu'on fasse trop confiance à
l'enfant et que nestor pas une prime
suffisamment région
mais paul gérin lajoie s'est fixé un
objectif et rien ne leur détournera bout
non d'une façon générale augmenter la
qualité de l'enseignement
quatre ans après son élection son rêve
de créer le ministère de l'éducation se
réalise
s'enclenche alors une petite révolution
il abolit les collèges classiques qui
n'est accessible qu'à une petite élite
et instaure un système d'éducation
public et gratuit c'est la naissance un
peu partout au québec de la maternelle
des polyvalentes et plus tard des cégeps
dorénavant l'éducation est obligatoire
jusqu'à 16 ans et un système de prêts et
bourses est créé pour les études
supérieures
les jeunes d elle la madeleine et de la
côte-nord le titre des andes ont pu avec
la révolution tranquille avoir accès à
un enseignement secondaire il y a
également le droit de participer à
l'activité de certaines organisations
internationales dans une allocution
devant le corps consulaire de montréal
en 1965 il exclut
la volonté du québec d'être un acteur
mondial pierre angulaire des relations
internationales de la province la
doctrine gérin-lajoie aînés doctrine
selon laquelle le québec peut signer des
ententes avec des pays souverains dans
ses champs de compétence
paul gérin lajoie qui est de la
politique active en 69
mais sa volonté de changer le monde
n'est toujours pas assouvi en 70 il
devient directeur de l' agence
canadienne de développement
international puis met sur pied la
fondation paul gérin-lajoie axée sur
l'éducation dans les pays défavorisés
d'afrique de l'ouest et la bonté du
concept que la fondation en plus ou
moins inventé c'est d'avoir les classes
d'alphabétisation pour les mères de
famille bien plus tard ce dernier legs
la fameuse dictée pgl son oeuvre sera
maintes fois récompensé avec les plus
grands honneurs
l'étude des liens j'aime et malgré sa
voix usée par une opération paul gérin
lajoie continuera d'enrichir le débat
public est encore tout récemment à 96
ans il présente un mémoire devant les
parlementaires à québec se portant à la
défense des élections scolaires
la démocratisation de l'éducation comme
fondement à l'enrichissement collectif
aura été son combat jusqu'au bout et si
matthew zions radio canada montréal